كارمن هنالك اكثر من اعلان واكثر من بلدات
تعرضت تعرضت لاطلاق نار وسقوط قذائف
واشارات روسيه الى خسائر في هذه البلدات
المواليه لروسيا
نعم هي حقيقه بلده حدوديه او مقاطعه كورسك
الحدوديه تعرضت لقصف وردنا قبل قليل عن
سقوط جريحين في هذه المقاطعه التي تتعرض
بشكل مكثف للقصف الاوكراني واتحدث حاكم
المقاطعه مع مقاطعه كورس عن اسقاط مسيره
كانت تحمل قذائف على كانت تحمل قذائف هذا
الامر يحيلنا الى ما تحدث عنه الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حين قال ان هناك
ضروره لتطوير الدفاعات الجويه في
المقاطعات الحدوديه والتحدث عن ضروره خلق
منطقه عازله في المرحله المقبله اذا ما
استمرت الاوضاع على ما هي عليه في هذه
المقاطعات الحدوديه على راسها كورس كما
ذكرت بل جورد وبريانسك ايضا هذه المقاطعات
تعرضت بشكل كبير لقصف اوكراني واستهدافات
في المرحله الماضيه وتستمر هذه
الاستهدافات في مقاطعه بيل جرود التي تقع
على
اذا ما ذهبنا الى الميادين المشتعله
مقاطعه على راس هذه الميادين وفيها عدد
كبير من الجبهات الجبهه الاولى هي جبهات
باخموت تحاول القوات الروسيه تعزيز
مواقعها ولتجاه باتجاه المدن التي ما زالت
تسيطر عليها القوات الاوكرانيه نتحدث هنا
عن
تم الحديث فجر اليوم عن سماع عدد من
الانفجارات في بالتحديد في مدينه
كراماتورسك وايضا تتحدث وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن صد هجمات للقوات الاوكرانيه في
محيط مدينه باخموت بالعوده الى مدينه
دنيتك حيث نتواجد ثلاث جبهات اساسيه في
ارضيافكا هناك حديث عن اختراقات قامت بها
القوات الروسيه في شمال غرب هذه الجبهه
وهذا الامر ايضا نشرت مواقع روسيه مواقع
عسكريه روسيه عن مقاطع مصوره تظهر استسلام
عدد من الجنود الاوكر على جبهه افديفكا
بالتحديد اذا ما ذهبنا جنوبا على جبهه
مارينكا وجبهه هناك صد مكثف لها الهجمات
الاوكرانيه التي تجري على هاتين الجبهتين
نذكر جيدا ان الهجوم المضاد كان بدا من
جبهه مارينكا بالتحديد عند هذا التقاطع
بين مقاطعات ومقاطعه
التي كانت توصف بالرماديه في الايام
الماضيه لم تعد رماديه واذا ما رصدنا
تحركات القوات كان الروسيه والاوكرانيه في
تلك المنطقه هناك كر وفر وهناك سيطره على
مدينه من هنا او على قريه بالاحرى او
تراجع من هناك ولكن خط
الفاصل بين الجبهتين وبين الطرفين ما زال
محددا في هذه المرحله هذا الهجوم المضاد
وهذه المعارك المستعره في تلك المنطقه
بالتحديد
والخسائر الفادحه التي تقول القوات
الروسيه انها الحقتها بالقوات الاوكرانيه
تحدث عنها يوم امس الرئيس الذي قال ان
خسائر القوات الاوكرانيه يمكن وصفها
بالكارثه وتحدث عن خساره 30% من العتاد
الذي تلقته اوكرانيا من الغرب كرم الناجو
خضار من دونيتسكا